I've been married to my husband for 30
years he earns a sixf figure salary and
I've been a stay-at-home mom he wanted
to manage our finances because working
together stressed him out and he didn't
want to argue I thought we lived a good
life but on a recent vacation I
overheard him checking account balances
on our credit cards and became concerned
so I started quietly researching I
discovered he was tearing up financial
documents and throwing them away so I
couldn't see them he has completed 95%
of a job buyout and taken loans on what
little retirement savings he had less
than 100K there's some significant
deceit whether it's an addiction it's
somebody else he's in love with or he's
got other pet projects he's trying to
work through um this is not just to
avoid confrontation this because he has
a different life